merci Jérôme ma chaleur de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de l'Oise donc
du groupe les républicains et membres de
la commission d'enquête parlementaire
sur le fond Marianne dont on va parler
dans quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est la question de
l'immigration et cette déclaration hier
de Yelle la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale le projet des républicains va
beaucoup trop loin dit-elle pour elle il
remet en cause le principe de notre
adhésion à l'Union européenne mais elle
appelle quand même à des compromis il
faut que chacun fasse un pas a-t-elle
dit il est possible ce compromis je ne
sais pas façon ça va être je veux dire
un moment de vérité aujourd'hui
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas de
majorité et ne pas se ne pas passer
aucun texte majeur de réforme et de
nouvelles lois pour
nécessaire pour le pays
[Musique]
nous avons repéré que nous étions pas
majoritaire aujourd'hui dans le pays
nous sommes à peu près majoritaire quand
même au Sénat
ça veut dire que le pays est bloqué et
Emmanuel Macron doit faire ses efforts
je comprends que pour l'aloche de la
macronie qui est encore majoritaire
parmi les élus peut-être pas parmi les
électeurs mais certainement parmi les
élus est un peu de mal avec un texte qui
est un texte de droite c'est certain et
bien assumé à la fois par Éric sciatique
Olivier berlex évidemment rue de
Retailleau est possible quelle pas vous
êtes prêt à faire vous en direction de
l'exécutif
en dehors d'une textes constitutionnel
qui a été proposée on a proposé deux
textes un d'ordre constitutionnel et un
une loi ordinaire si ils prennent déjà
la loi ordinaire et bien ils auront fait
un grand pas
donc ce sera ce sera peut-être ça le
compromis on écarte vous êtes prêt à
écarter la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle et à trouver un accord
sur la proposition de l'ordinaire je
pense que ce serait raisonnable et c'est
là-dessus que nous réfléchissons mais
nous montrons aussi quelle est la
5garité et ce que serait un projet
alternatif à Emmanuel Macron et une
autre alternative que le Front national
que pour l'instant Emmanuel Macron
pousse à sa suite l'autre thème on l'a
vu dans le journal c'est Manuel Macron
qui a donc entamé hier une série de
déplacements autour de la souveraineté
industrielle de la France le message
pour lui c'est qu'il faut que la France
retrouve sa souveraineté dans des
secteurs notamment les médicaments on
l'a vu est-ce que vous partagez cette
vision j'ai partagé avant lui et plutôt
lui qui partage la mienne j'ai écrit des
papiers à bien avant la crise sanitaire
sur les problèmes de chaîne de valeur et
qu'il fallait effectivement à retrouver
de la souveraineté
on ne sait pas aujourd'hui définir en
France c'est le ministère de l'économie
dans les strictement incapable les
chaînes de valeur c'est-à-dire ce dont
on a besoin parce que pour faire de la
chimie ça va on peut le faire mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe la chimie et les
médicaments il y avait un temps la
France était le premier pays premier
pays pour les médicaments nous en sommes
maintenant le 5e donc on voit bien que
au fur et à mesure et Emmanuel Macron a
été plus ou moins au pouvoir pendant
plus de 10 ans 11 ans pendant ces
dernières années il a participé la chute
et donc il a découvert il trois ans il y
a trois ans déjà avec le covid que a
peut-être qu'on était pas indépendant
sur les médicaments il découvre et il
fait les choses avec trois ans de retard
et il a promis j'irai bien écouter ses
paroles prochainement donc là encore on
fait beaucoup d'annonces et on n'a pas
beaucoup de résultats on a même les
résultats inverse depuis de nombreuses
années alors il inverse la vapeur tant
mieux je ne peux que m'en réjouir mais
ça va prendre encore de nombreuses
années parce que le cap n'est pas clair
on va parler des finances puisque
évidemment c'est un sujet que vous
suivez ici au Sénat et les tractations
les discussions autour du budget 2024 on
commençait alors comme pour le précédent
budget Gabriel Attal fait le construire
avec les parlementaires et il souhaite
que ce budget soit le budget des classes
moyennes il faut que les Français les
classes moyennes en est pour leurs
impôts et pour leur travail vous
pourriez tomber d'accord là-dessus je
crois que c'est à peu près des phrases
qui ont été dites par des ministres de
l'économie depuis que je suis le sujet
c'était un peu plus d'un quart de siècle
donc ça va le déficit et la dette n'ont
jamais été aussi élevé donc on peut on
peut estimer que cette phrase va avec le
déficit qui continue à être au dessus
des essais européens
et on n'a pas les moyens on est plutôt à
la réduction et aux économies plutôt que
au gestes pour les classes moyennes faut
pas faire de gestes en direction de ces
classes moyennes ce que l'on arrête
quand on fait un plan de relance
moyenne je veux dire une chose d'une
part les classes moyennes se sentent
toujours oubliées parce qu'on fait
beaucoup de choses pour les très bas
salaires et on fait jamais rien pour les
classes moyennes et puis après on parle
les ultra-riches pour agiter la foule
donc là les classes moyennes ces gens
qui sont qui ont viendront recevoir un
et demi pour cent au 1er juillet
prochain les fonctionnaires les
fonctionnaires savez-vous signer que
depuis 2010 et j'ai fait les calculs et
j'ai les tiens à disposition les
fonctionnaires ont perdu 18% de pouvoir
d'achat 18% c'est juste deux mois deux
mois de salaire on a fait perdre deux
mois de salaire depuis 2010 au
fonctionnaire évidemment qui se sentent
oubliés
vous connaissez une seule personne qui
dit on va en disant vous avez perdre
deux mois de salaire et qu'il accepte
ces deux mois de pouvoir d'achat qui ont
été perdus et donc là avec le 1 et demi
alors que l'inflation est à 5 on
continue à maltraiter en vérité les
classes moyennes donc il faut le faire
quelque chose dans le budget 2024 pour
ces classes moyennes qu'est-ce que vous
allez proposer
nous vous savez on est très limité parce
qu'on est sur l'article 40
c'est celui qui interdit d'alourdir les
charges publiques dans la Constitution
il a dit que cette année il commencerait
encore plus tôt son dialogue de Bercy
tout début septembre mais il se trouve
que j'ai fait avec les parlements je
trouve que j'ai déjà fait du budget dans
ma vie j'étais conseiller de ministre
j'en ai fait plusieurs fois si au
Parlement et grosso modo à la fin août
vous connaissez toutes les dépenses et à
peu près tout est recettes donc tout ça
ça va être des micros aménagement c'est
de la poudre aux yeux pour essayer de
faire passer le texte et pour essayer de
nous mettre dans leur dans leur impasse
je ne serai pas dans leur impasse je
serai dans le dialogue mais pas dans
leur impasse
au Sénat et l'actualité c'est la
commission d'enquête sur le fond
Marianne au cœur de ses travaux vous
appartenez à cette commission d'enquête
Marlène Schiappa additionner ce matin
hier c'est Mohamed Sifaoui président de
l'association qui a le plus bénéficié du
fond Marianne qui aurait dû être entendu
par vous et pour la seconde fois il ne
s'est pas présenté devant les sénateurs
on va voir pourquoi avec notre
journaliste parle
[Musique]
donc pas pu être entendu hier matin par
la commission d'enquête sanatoriale sur
le fond Marianne
fois que le directeur des opérations de
l'uspm l'Union des sociétés d'éducation
physique et de préparation militaire
rate son rendez-vous avec les sénateurs
la première fois le journaliste est
dirigeant de l'association avait fourni
un certificat médical cette fois c'est
la justice elle-même qui empêchait
l'audition comme l'a annoncé le
président de la commission d'enquête et
des Finances Claude Raynal en ouverture
des débats
il s'avère que depuis six heures du
matin une perquisition est en cours à
son domicile et donc en sa présence
il n’est en conséquence pas possible
pour celui-ci et pour des raisons vous
en conviendrez totalement indépendante
sa volonté de pouvoir honorer cette
convocation voilà le message que nous
avons reçu ce matin dès lors cette
audition n'aura pas lieu
évidemment avec le rapporteur nous le
regrettons
et nous verrons comment nous pouvons
avancer dans ce dossier par la suite
dans quelle mesure la justice et la
commission d'enquête ne se marchent pas
sur les pieds bien c'est toute la
question cette convocation Mohamed
cifaoui était connue de longue date et
n'avait pas pu échapper à la justice
l'avocat de l'intéressé Bernard benayam
s'interroge lui-même auprès de nos
confrères de RTL je cite sur la
concomitance de ces événements qui
rendent impossible la présence de son
client face au sénateur mais pour Claude
rénale encore il n'y a pas de sujet
le parquet a ses règles le
fonctionnement a aussi son agenda propre
nous respectons le parquet dans ses
actions
voilà et donc imagine pas autre chose et
si je devais dire
les choses un peu clairement sur sur ce
sujet je pense que
l'audition de Monsieur Sifaoui aurait
peut-être pu être prise en compte par le
parquet de la même façon que nous
respectons nous le travail du parquet
d'ailleurs un télescopage qui n'est pas
sans rappeler une autre affaire au
moment de la commission d'enquête
Benalla le procureur de Paris de
l'époque Rémy Heights avait publié un
communiqué cinglant le parquet constate
que les investigations de la mission
d'information ont de fait recouvert un
champ en grande partie similaire à celui
de procédure judiciaire toujours en
cours conduite dans le cadre de deux
informations judiciaires distinctes
ouverte par un parquet de Paris et
Mathias pour qu'on comprenne bien quel
est le champ d'action de la commission
d'enquête parlementaire et bien les
commissions d'enquête parlementaires
dépendent de l'article 51 alinéa 2 de la
Constitution pardon et prévoit qu'une
commission peut donc être créée dans le
but de recueillir des éléments
d'information dans des cas précis contre
l'action du gouvernement et évaluer les
politiques publiques avec plusieurs
garde-fous aucun contrôle sur le
président de la République que cela
n'implique pas d'effet c'est en produit
dans une des deux assemblées ou encore
des faits qui relèveraient d'une enquête
judiciaire dans ce cas précis les
sénateurs ont donc limité leur enquête
sur les conditions d'attribution des
subventions et les mécanismes de
contrôle mise en place par l'exécutif
alors pour Jean-François Husson
rapporteurs de la commission d'enquête
et bien ça respecte ces prérogatives
nous sommes en qui d'ailleurs
d'une saisine auprès du garde des sceaux
de manière à ce qu'il nous soit précisé
si d'aventure il y avait des sujets de
conflits possibles ou d'impossibilité ça
n'est pas le cas et je crois pouvoir
dire que jusqu'à présent les retours non
seulement de la presse mais le retour de
l'opinion
nous conforte dans le sérieux du travail
qui est fait pour poser les choses pour
regarder avec objectivité le déroulement
des faits les versions des uns des
autres les questions voilà besoin
d'éclairer et puis je rappelle que c'est
aussi le je dirais la forme la plus
élaborée de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement et de la dépense de
l'argent public
alors monsieur le sénateur comment être
sûr que la commission d'enquête à
laquelle vous appartenez ne se substitue
pas à la justice où sont fixés les
limites finalement
limite elles sont fixées clairement par
d'une part la Constitution et d'autre
part parce que le président rénal nous a
dit alors c'était peut-être africain
mais sur les questions qu'on pouvait
poser pour ne pas
arriver sur le champ du judiciaire nous
l'avons déjà fait nous l'avons
parfaitement fait contrairement à ce que
dit le procureur Edge que j'aime
beaucoup par ailleurs que j'ai plusieurs
fois dans ma vie dans d'autres fonctions
le Parlement je le rappelle parce que il
y a un moment il faut rappeler ce qu'est
l'ordre de la Constitution dans l'ordre
de la Constitution le Parlement est
avant l'exécutif ça ne se va pas
toujours de soi mais c'est bien ça
l'ordre et c'est avant l'ordre
judiciaire c'est bien le Parlement qui
fait la loi qui contrôle l'action de
l'exécutif et le judiciaire est après et
ça il se trouve d'ailleurs que la
justice est saisie
que le Parlement que la commission des
finances a choisi d'enquêter sur le
sujet donc faut quand même pas confondre
l'ordre des choses et c'était la même
chose sur l'affaire Benalla à chaque
fois finalement le parquet je le
rappelle processeur auprès du garde des
sceaux
protège un peu trop un peu trop vite ou
un peu trop lentement cette enquête
l'ouverture il pouvait la faire un mois
après ça n'aurait pas changé grand chose
ils ont choisi et c'est très bien et
nous ça nous conforte on est presque des
lanceurs d'alerte pour la justice qui ne
oublie de regarder certains dossiers
donc c'est très bien
on dit des choses moi j'étais sceptique
au départ sur cette commission d'enquête
je l'avais dit sur public sénat.fr voilà
pas sur votre plateau j'étais sceptique
peut-être qu'une simple action simple
contrôle avec les pouvoirs du président
de la commission des finances aurait été
possible et en fait non parce qu'il faut
que les ministres qui ne sont plus en
charge puissent venir s'expliquer en
l'occurrence pour être positionné
aujourd'hui Marlène Schiappa dans ses
nouvelles fonctions et qu'elle réponde
au titre des fonctions précédentes
qu'elle avait sur ce fond Marianne et
bien il fallait que ce soit transformé
en commission donc
et ça nous l'avons fait et c'est très
utile on le voit bien d'ailleurs avec
Monsieur cifaoui donc je ne connais pas
qui est effectivement la première fois
était malade et j'espère qu'il s'est
bien remis mais là il était réveillé
très tôt hier et nous aussi parce qu'on
s'est levé tôt pour venir à cette
audition et on était un petit peu déçu
alors il va peut-être venir demain il
est reconvoqué on verra comment est-ce
que vous l'interprétez vous cette
perquisition du coup un rappel alors de
la justice ou non pas du tout
honnêtement moi j'y vois enfin voilà
chacun a son calendrier on peut pas
tenir compte du calendrier de tout le
monde et des calendriers aussi pour les
enquêteurs et les calendriers pour la
justice moi je n'ai pas de de
honnêtement je ne vois pas de choses
cachées de complot de la justice contre
le Parlement ou un inverse non un moment
faut que chacun soit dans son dans sa
ligne et nous nous suivons la nôtre vous
avez une question là-dessus sur cette
audition justement qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de cette audition de Mohamed
Sifaoui alors l'avantage aussi de la
commission d'enquête c'est de c'est la
seule où vous dites toute la vérité
quand vous êtes devant le magistrat vous
avez le droit de mentir lorsque vous
êtes accusé ça ne va pas de soi les
Français n'ont pas forcément ça en tête
parce que on est obligé de faux
témoignage lorsqu'on est témoins
lorsqu'on est accusé on n'est pas accusé
de côté voyage ici nous avons eu quand
même des dysfonctionnements majeurs ou
c'était monsieur cifaoui nous disent un
certain nombre d'interlocuteurs qui
appelaient le secrétariat général et qui
le disait ah bah je sors du cabinet de
labyiste et donc j'ai besoin de temps
c'est un peu bizarre voilà donc c'est
pas le mode de fonctionnement normal et
nous interrogeons sur le fonctionnement
normal de l'État dans l'attribution de
ces subventions et il se trouve que
c'est subventions c'est ce que Dieu
prétend la justice aurait peut-être été
un peu détourné donc on n'est pas du
tout sur la même chose nous on est sur
la méthode d'octroi des subventions pour
qui pourquoi suivant est des règles
normales et la justice dit ah bah
peut-être que ces subventions étaient
mal utilisées on n'est pas là-dedans
bonne séparation donc on va entendre
monsieur sipalu oui qui est le principal
intéressé nous dira sa vérité est-ce que
depuis le début de ces auditions puisque
ça fait maintenant plusieurs jours
qu'elles ont commencé vous avez
l'impression d'être face à un possible
scandale d'État dans cette affaire alors
on n'est pas sur des milliards mais on
est quand même sur des centaines de
milliers d'euros c'est quand même
beaucoup d'impôts des Français et
effectivement sur une très mauvaise
utilisation c'est à dire que peut-être
que ce que nous allons soulever la Cour
des comptes l'aurait fait quelques
années après mais là il se trouve que le
temps du Parlement est un peu plus
rapide que le temps de la Cour des
comptes mais j'aimerais bien lire le
rapport de la Cour des comptes sur ce
sujet là aussi après
absolument pas peut-être d'une coalition
avec votre famille politique et le
gouvernement merci Mathias on vous
retrouve tout à l'heure on va voir
l'actualité dans votre département de
l'Oise maintenant on retrouve Jean-Marc
chevaucher rédacteur en chef adjoint du
Courrier Picard bonjour Jean-Marc merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Jean-Marc vous
allez nous parler des sénatoriales ce
sera je le rappelle le 24 septembre
prochain et vous allez nous faire un
point sur les sénatoriales dans l'Oise
on peut en parler parce que
il y a un mot qui qui définit la
situation actuelle c'est chacun chacun
pour soi et Dieu pour tous il y a à
droite trois candidatures monsieur
Bachir qui est sur le plateau monsieur
Paco qui est un candidat libre édouard
Courtial qui est ancien Allaire et macro
compatible alors il bénéficie de
l'absence de de candidature
Renaissance dans le département il y a
aussi une candidature rassemble
nationale il y a aussi
la gauche qui est divisée qui a été
ressorti Walter Amsalem ancien maire de
Beauvais
fringant nonagénaire pour conduire une
liste donc voilà on a une situation
assez particulière alors ma question
Jérôme Bacher c'est dans cette dans
cette affaire est-ce que vous
espérez peut-être prendre le leadership
de la droite dans le département puisque
je vous reconnais une position plus
claire politiquement que celle des des
autres listes que je viens de citer
merci jean-marcocher et bonjour à vous
non j'essaye de garder la même ligne moi
je suis fidèle à mes engagements fidèles
à mes vidéos je suis un gaulliste social
voilà assez assez clairement depuis le
début je suis pas prêt à tout je crois
que je suis pas très bac au compatible
j'ai dû l'expliquer un peu sur le
plateau juste avant je suis pas très
macro compatible je ne crois pas au
président de la République c'est un
simple ainsi il concentre le pouvoir
tout seul il a raison tout seul et donc
il y a pas de coalition possible ça
serait juste du débauchage de poste
cette coalition donc ce serait pas
effectivement un programme donc il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui de de coalition possible
la coalition ça se fait juste avant les
élections ou juste au lendemain ça se
fait pas un an après pour dire tout ça
c'est pas sérieux car je suis très
respectueux moi du vote des Français
donc j'essaye d'être très clair sur ma
vie et peut-être que pour les grands
électeurs qu'il y a trois lignes
différentes à dire sur le centre droit
et la droite peut-être que c'est pas si
mal c'est peut-être aussi ça la droite
en France c'est que peut-être quelque
chose d'un petit peu éparpillé alors
j'espère rassembler le plus possible
avec une liste vraiment formidable avec
des terrains Sophie Mercier ou de nippe
un conseiller régional président de la
commission agriculture à la région on a
une très très belle liste enfin moi je
suis très fier de ce qui est très
terrain et c'est peut-être ça la vraie
droite ici elle veut se reconstruire
c'est une droite de terrain nous
obtenons encore la plupart des villes
une bonne partie des départements et des
régions c'est parce que notre action
locale est audible une droite
pragmatique mais une droite qui ne dévie
pas et là où on dévie ben c'est
peut-être là où on se perd et je pense
que aujourd'hui au niveau national on
manque de leader grand leader affirmé on
a des gens très très doués pour une
Retailleau Laurent Wauquiez Éric cioti
pour l'instant il n'arrive pas encore il
n'arrive pas encore à émerger tout seul
le milieu est placé vous allez dire que
je suis un peu constant dans mes
positions c'est Xavier Bertrand
aujourd'hui
dans la droite classique clairement les
sondages le disent
et ce qui pèse aux parties les
républicains je ne suis pas sûr là où je
suis certain c'est qu'il pèse beaucoup
plus dans chez les électeurs de la
droite et du centre parce qu'ils sentent
chez lui cette position que vous
appeliez tout à l'heure sur les classes
moyennes c'est peut-être l'homme des
classes moyennes et c'est ça peut-être
une ligne à avoir c'est de la mienne
c'est celle du glisse social on va
parler évidemment des républicains du
National mais sur l'Oise du coup est-ce
que les divisions de la droite peuvent
vous coûter un siège est-ce que ça peut
profiter au rassemblement national je ne
crois pas honnêtement le plus probable
il ne faut pas se mentir c'est
aujourd'hui que les trois sénateurs qui
siègent dans le groupe les républicains
soit réélu mais moi j'ai dit je suis
républicain et je resterai au groupe les
républicains Olivier Pacaud était
indépendant la fois dernière et dit
qu'il est resté indépendant tout en
étant apparenté au groupe les
républicains et Édouard Courtial dans le
Courrier Picard de dimanche vous voyez
que je lis le Courrier Picard Jean-Marc
chevaucher a dit qu'il ne savait pas où
il irait si j'ai mais il était pour
cette alliance dont vous parliez chacun
pourra s'y retrouver ou pas on essaie
d'être fidèle à mes engagements éclaire
dans ma ligne c'est la position de notre
liste avec des gens vraiment formidables
au-delà d'une position claire je vous
reconnais également de scène lecture
que des loches ce matin ça marche et on
va inviter justement les noter les
spectateurs à lire le courrier picard on
va regarder la une Courrier Picard
accompagnant d'élèves en situation de
handicap pour mieux être inclus c'est le
titre ce matin de votre journée merci
Jean-Marc chevauché merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous on parlait
justement des républicains il y a des
rumeurs de remaniement qui sont de plus
en plus insistantes je ne serai pas au
gouvernement c'est un scoop voilà mais
ça c'est déjà une info
entre les républicains et l'exécutif et
la majorité présidentielle est-ce que
les républicains ont d'autres choix ah
oui nous avons d'autres choix le choix
c'est de faire sur chaque texte notre
proposition c'est ce que nous venons de
faire sur l'immigration sur chaque choix
essentiel nous devons faire notre
proposition c'est extrêmement important
pour voir la différence et que justement
les Français qui ont voté pour un
président sans programme puisse
continuer peut-être à l'avenir à avoir
autre chose comme à venir que Marine Le
Pen qui aujourd'hui dans un fauteuil
porté par Emmanuel Macron pour la fois
prochaine je suis extrêmement inquiet de
cette position qui consiste à
affoler les foules en vérité et les
précipiter tous les électeurs dans les
bras de Marine Le Pen donc nous devons
être
le parti alternatif à partir de
rassemblement parce qu'on voit bien que
aujourd'hui peut-être nous sommes dans à
l'étage chez les républicains
l'élection présidentielle et ça sera
cette élection décisive il faut attendre
un petit peu moi je pense que Xavier
Bertrand a un rôle à jouer que David
Lisnard est absolument remarquable
Laurent Wauquiez dans sa dernière
interview dans un magazine a été
vraiment extrêmement bon et on manque
pas de talent mais il va falloir se
rassembler et pas se diviser en disant
mais on manque d'un leader oui il faut
passer maintenant des talents au
leadership par les idées et par la
volonté une candidature à la
présidentielle chez vous pour le moment
pour le moment on le voit bien dans les
sondages
naturels il est moins naturel mais son
changement de de positionnement sa
nouvelle ligne je vais dire ça comme
cela plus clairement exprimé en tout cas
dans un magazine me plaît beaucoup elle
est très rassurante et elle montre toute
la capacité de l'homme c'est un homme
qui a vraiment des capacités
exceptionnelles on le voit dans sa
région comme vous avez Bertrand on le
voit dans sa région mais chacun est une
attitude différente et le leader qui
sortira c'est celui qui rassemblera et
c'est cela qu'il faut faire il va
falloir maintenant que les forces
montent
le samedi nous avons un congrès chez les
républicains on va voir comment c'est à
fonctionner cela et bien ces états
généraux
des républicains
mais pas très macrocompatible en vérité
mais il de préparation de l'avenir
depuis le bas avec des idées et puis un
leader qui se prépare vraiment à l'être
à rassembler le pays et Xavier Bertrand
sera là samedi je ne sais pas je n'ai
pas tout son agenda pour ma part je n'y
serais pas parce que j'ai un événement
privé voilà comment voilà faut rien y
voir de politique bon là c'est un
événement religieux en l'occurrence
merci
première demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans
le club des territoires on parlera de
l'avenir du gouvernement Elizabeth borne
peut-elle tenir et Emmanuel Macron
peut-il passer un accord avec les
républicains débat avec nos
éditorialistes à suivre d'abord on
accueille notre prochaine invité
Stanislas Gang